on bitcoin specifically the kind of need
for non-political asset that is for
enemies is stronger than ever I mean if
we look at all the kind of geopolitical
craziness that took place this year you
now have countries that are trying to
move off a dollar standard as you know
the U.S basically uh said that they're
going to be using Swift as a weapon
moving forward you can essentially just
get completely cut off from your
reserves and that's what happened to
Russia earlier this year and the entire
you know Financial system and so I think
you have a lot of countries that are
probably waking up to the value
proposition of BTC over the last year
you know wouldn't be surprised if you
have Sovereign wealth funds or central
banks and you know developing countries
at least that are probably accumulating
some BTC down here